we begin with breaking news from eastern
afghanistan where at least 12 women have
been killed
in a stampede they'd gathered with
thousands of other people in a stadium
in jalalabad to apply for visas to
pakistan
the pakistani consulate started issuing
visas again last week
after a seven-month pause due to the
coronavirus let's go live now to kabul
filio control fury is there for us
philia what more do we know about what
happened
well adrian like you mentioned the
incident happened earlier this morning
outside a stadium in the eastern city of
jalalabad
where normally hundreds of afghans would
gather every morning just to get a
number
so then they could process their visa
applications at the pakistani
consulate so they could travel uh to uh
to jalalabad now local tells us that
yesterday there were some rumors
spreading on social media
that the pakistani consulate today would
hand out more visas than usual and that
caused a lot more people that
would normally gather outside that
stadium to go and try to go
and get inside so as a result when the
gates opened
from what locals tell us there were
thousands of people who try to rush
in as fast as they can as they could and
that's what caused the deadly stampede
adrian
why are so many people so desperate to
get a visa
to pakistan
well adrian pakistan is one of only a
handful of
countries where afghans can get a visa
and travel to
the afghan passport continues to rank as
the worst
in the world for international travel so
afghans are pretty much trapped here so
any chance they have to get out of here
for many reasons
for example in pakistan a lot of them
they have family there there's a lot of
afghan refugees families that are
separated
and a lot of them also have to travel to
pakistan for medical reasons because
afghanistan has
one of the worst health care systems in
the world
and that's why there's so many of them
trying to make it to pakistan
and you do get the same sense outside
the pakistani embassy here in kabul
where
every morning hundreds of afghans gather
a lot of them are sick a lot of them
have to spend
the night there just so that they can
make it in the next morning and try to
get a visa for pakistan a process
that has become a lot stricter and
harder uh in the last couple of years
adrian
felio reporting live there from kabul
failure many thanks indeed